millions monfils a priori je ne serais
pas là pour ton anniversaire c'est pas
de la mauvaise volonté mais laisse moi
d'expliquer comment j'en suis arrivée là
je te souhaite un jour des mais comme
j'aime et amer quand je repense à notre
histoire
j'ai que des bons souvenirs bush c'est
pas pour vanter mais je nous avait
construit une [ __ ] belle vie jusqu'à
ce matin là qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ils étaient à peine 9 heures et demie et
il pleuvait dans ta chambre
je construis une somme qu'on forge sur
thur nombre bon j'avais peut-être pas
choisi le meilleur entrepreneur ta mère
panique toujours trop vite mais moi je
sais la rassurer c'est pour ça qu'elle
même
mais car malade et c'est là que j'ai
reçu ce sms
ta mère se faisait ambiancé par un
torero [ __ ] alors oui c'est vrai j'ai
pas pris la bonne décision mais je t'ai
cherché partout je t'assure
oui qu'est ce que tu fais là bonjour
c'est mon bureau quand même ça t'empêche
pas dire bonjour j'ai même demandé de
l'aide à mon ex
mais c'était un peu gênant alors je suis
allé voir tonton vincent et là ça a
vraiment dérapé
tu vois milo dans ta vie tu va traverser
des moments difficiles
laurent stop la loose et ben tu devra
rester optimiste il ya l'huissier passer
un quart d'heure
bon ok ça n'explique toujours pas ce que
je fais là mais j'ai très envie de
pisser dans ma position je sens que je
vais pas aimer